Speaker 1: All right, let me not waste time,
because we have so many things to talk about
and jump right into this next story. This is an
interesting sort of glimpse into the mind of those
who are talking about impeaching Joe Biden. We've
seen radical members of Congress like Marjorie
Taylor Green as well as Lauren Bobber and others
talk about. I have filed articles of impeachment
against Joe Biden. I plan to impeach Joe Biden.
If we take the House, we're going to impeach Joe
Biden, etc.. And aside from the fact that there's
no reason to justify an impeachment of Joe Biden,
there's no justification for impeaching Joe Biden.
One of the things I've mentioned is if you impeach
Joe Biden, Kamala Harris becomes president of
the United States. Is that is that really what
they want to achieve? And if you impeach Kamala
Harris, then Nancy Pelosi becomes president of the
United States, unless you impeach Biden and Harris
and get them convicted and removed after taking
control of the House, in which case the Republican
speaker of the House would become president of the
United States. To his credit, a right wing
radio host, Glenn Beck, actually confronted
Republican Congresswoman Lauren Lauren Bobert with
this and said, well, but if you impeach Biden,
then it goes to Harris. Does that really
make sense? Is that really what you want? And
listen to the level of delusion? With which Lauren
Bobert responded to this accurate issue with
Lauren Bowerbirds plan, let's listen together out.
Speaker 5: Kamala Harris is president.
Does it get any better? Right.
Speaker 2: So, of course, that is
the number one question. When you start thinking
about impeachment and and discussing that, you
start going down the list. What do we really want,
President Harris? Do we really want President
Pelosi? She certainly has shown what she does with
the People's House here in Washington, D.C. I can
imagine what she would do with the White House.
Speaker 1: OK, so what's the plan? Lauren,
tell us. Listen to this.
Speaker 2: So I have legislation
that will be introduced in impeaching both
Biden and Harris and Nancy Pelosi can follow
them out the freakin door. She certainly needs
to be held accountable for this as well. And
we have called as the Freedom Caucus.
We have called on Leader McCarthy
to introduce a resolution to vacate the chair.
Speaker 1: OK, they don't control the House of
Representatives. So there might
be a few more seconds here.
Holy cow. Yeah, oh, so even Glenn Beck is
surprised by the level of stupidity of this,
so of course not. So there's 99 percent of
this is gutter trash. One percent of it is
something we actually need to be aware of.
So. OK, what's the gutter trash? The gutter
trash is if that assuming that for as long as
they don't control the House or the Senate,
this is all just idiocy. You're not impeaching Joe
Biden. You're not impeaching Joe Biden together
with Kamala Harris. And Kevin McCarthy is not you
know, he can introduce whatever he wants to vacate
the speakership and take it from Nancy Pelosi.
None of it none of it is happening, even if
they take control of the House in twenty, twenty
two. And somehow they managed to actually, quote,
impeach, which remember the house files, the
articles, then you have a trial in the Senate.
Even if they manage to do it, the Senate is not
going to convict on the basis of what's happened
so far. The Senate is not going to convict
Joe Biden. The Senate is not going to convict
Kamala Harris. So. Ninety nine percent of this
is just nonsense and delusions and it shows us
how delusional she is. But. I think it is almost
certain that if Republicans do take control of
the House in November of 2022, just 14 months
from now, well, the election is in 14 months,
taking over would be in 16 and a half months. I
think they absolutely impeach Joe Biden. I think
that there is no question that these Republicans
are furious about the fact that Donald Trump
was impeached twice for things he deserved to
be impeached for. And they are determined to
impeach Joe Biden. So the plan of impeachment
might work if they get the majority in 22.
No Senate is going to actually convict Joe Biden
based on what he's done so far. Certainly not
Kamala Harris either. And the idea of when you're
in the minority vacating the chair, it's just
absolutely delusional. But good for Glenn Beck for
confronting her about it. I'm glad that he did.